[تصفيق]
تم رفع دعوى قضائية من قبل تركة
رجل توفي عام 2021 بعد أن أمضى
20 يومًا في الحبس الانفرادي في
سجن مقاطعة جاكسون في إنديانا ،
تم القبض على جوشوا ماكليمر 29
وسجنه لنتف شعر ممرضة أثناء تلقيه
العلاج في مكان قريب
وفقًا للدعوى القضائية ، كان لدى ماكليمور
تاريخ من مرض انفصام الشخصية وتعاطي المخدرات
وكان يعاني من
أزمة صحية نفسية وقت اعتقاله.
20 يومًا التالية
حصلت سي إن إن على مقاطع فيديو محررة من
كاميرا مراقبة مثبتة في السقف في الزنزانة من محامي الأسرة
وفقًا للدعوى القضائية ،
شرب آيدن القليل جدًا أثناء وجوده في عزلة
بسبب الذهان الذي ألقى أو أسقط
طعامه على الأرض
وفقًا للدعوى القضائية التي خسرها.
45 رطلاً في أقل من ثلاثة أسابيع
كشف تشريح الجثة أن السبب المباشر
لوفاته كان فشلًا في العديد من الأعضاء
بسبب رفض الأكل أو الشرب مع تغير
الحالة العقلية بسبب مرض انفصام الشخصية غير المعالج.
إنكوربوريتد الرعاية الصحية